so yeah he says um full of good old boys
raised up right Trump trump Trump trump
Trump trump Trump trump
[Laughter]
[Music]
so have you guys heard what about a guy
named Jason Aldean oh that is my dude
Jason yeah he's a country music singer
oh okay this is why this is why is he
the the the
small town guy to try that in the small
town guy is he gay is he the gay one
what I don't think that he's gay have
you guys seen the uh like real the real
country singer battles
nah my feet is weird so they've been
having these battles between gay country
singers and like and then they'll be
like we're in the bus
and then I was like oh you're not gay
enough and then you're like I'ma suck a
dick and behind a cactus whatever and
I'm just like and they're just both gay
battling their country songs Back and
Forth
I agree your feet is weird
Jason Aldean he just did a song called
try that in a small town and it is
getting like [__] lit up in the media
like they're basically saying it's a dog
whistle for all kinds of racism
try that in a small try that in a small
town so I'm gonna read you some of the
lyrics and you guys tell me if this is
completely [__] up and racist trying
to add in a small time sucker punch
somebody on a sidewalk carjack an old
lady at a red light pull a gun on the
owner of a liquor store you think it's
cool we'll act a fool if you like and
yeah is spelled y a and not y-o-u
because it's a country music song okay
cuss out a cop spit in his face stomp on
the flag and light it up yeah you think
you're tough we'll try that in a small
town
see how far you make it down the road
around here we take care of our own you
cross that line it won't take long for
you to find out I recommend you don't
try that in a small town that actually
sounds like a really nice place to live
yeah oh my that sounds so safe I want to
go to a small town now wait are they
saying that this is racist
it's coded racist dog whistles so
there's no small towns that are
non-white that protect each other and I
know like that's racist that's racist to
think like application like that it's
racist carjack an old lady that only
white people I didn't think like protect
each other just because a white guy's
singing There's places there's small
towns in Hawaii that have no white
people that all [__] watch each other
yup and then like they're like the [__]
are they talking about it actually
internationally makes sense there's
small islands in the Philippines that
have this sentiment there's small towns
in Tennessee that are all La ocean and
they have this bro they're small towns
in L.A well la is a collection of cities
right but I remember in our block like
it didn't matter if you're Asia Mexican
or whatever you watch each other's back
and if somebody comes in your
neighborhood and they look like they're
about to tag or do something you're like
where the [__] you from like yeah that's
normal it's true because it is a that
that's what makes it funny the
implication of racism is hilarious
because like another white person on the
left will see this and go to a black
dude and go dude that's [__] up that
he's talking about you
that's the only thing that
to start why do you think that's me
because the blasters could be from South
Central and he could be like my small
town will do this exactly Jack [__]
that Grandma's car everyone in this
[__] town would like they will [__]
you up what the [__] but it is true that
like when they say that crimes like that
are higher in urban cities or bigger
cities that's [__] true yeah because
there's more pizza man it's different
you know yeah it's not like race-based
it's just bigger cities people don't
watch each other's back as much but it
is if you're saying it's race-based yeah
yeah yeah yeah but that's not what he's
saying I think it's just because it's
country and it's a white guy doing it
yeah they're just thinking like oh he's
talking about black people like that's
what they're thinking yeah yeah well now
that you guys hung yourselves I'll read
the rest of the lyrics
Fried Chicken
I think he gets into like cooking dogs
and [__] yeah it's like wait what
so yeah he says um full of good old boys
raised up right Trump trump Trump trump
Trump trump
[Laughter]
so it's sick so is it is it a is it a
build up like EDM song yeah
I don't know if that's how it's
emphasizing song I haven't heard the
song but I think it's like
that I think I read something where like
sung or so people were pissed after the
music video because of the imagery with
the words and then oh they're mad at the
music video the the imagery because he
shows Riot footage he was showing them
oh well I need to see it just so
happened at the moment what the the
lyrics he was saying and it was matching
with a bunch of black folks doing you
know protests writing whatever so it's
like I think that's where they're like
oh they're that's why they're like he
was talking about I see yeah
here's the uh here's the music video I'm
not gonna play this on obviously or
we'll get wrecked oh
that looked like January 6 dude
where's the tiki torches at
where's the dude with a raccoon hat
oh it did if he got that guy yeah the
shaman oh there's no Asian hay footage I
feel left out man yeah we should put
some Asian I want some like Asian
grandmas getting beat up or something
it's funny because who wouldn't want to
live in the town that he painted in this
it sounds awesome who wouldn't want that
why why do we not want that it sounds
like [__] Toontown a Disneyland
I mean this video is very topical say
that
I I saw more white women that they were
depicting more than anything else so far
yeah there was a white lady run yelling
at a cop there was a white lady and
dancing in front of cops yeah now
there's great lady with her [__]
pointing at a cop yeah it's always the
point we're in a trucker hat we're an
all black All Blacks
I mean so far it's 90 performance you
know another thing too is um they were
saying that
they did this performance in front of a
courthouse
that has some type of civil rights or
significance to something along the
lines
so we have to really dig to find the
race no I forgot what dog whistle it's a
dogwood
it was like it was where they got
segregation or one of those things like
um you know disbanded or whatever and
then I saw a great I don't know some guy
on Twitter posted basically like he
actually just read some rap lyrics where
it's like I'm gonna [__] your mom and
I'll kill you I'm gonna even kill you
yeah yeah and it's like that's not
really a dog whistle that's like pretty
on the nose it's pretty much the same
what you're gonna do these rappers are
trying to have sex with my girlfriend
all the time
and they want to cuck me really bad yeah
dude did you see that like weird debate
about the this other chant called kill
the boar what's that you're talking
about it's not the yeah South Africa
yeah and it's like they're saying that
that's like an opposite on the opposite
of the spectrum to that where kill the
boys like it it makes it seem like
they're telling you to kill like the
white people in South Africa oh that's
what the boar means I guess that's what
it's implicating but then the on the the
same side that's calling that races is
calling kill the boar not racist yeah
that's so weird that's so strange I'm
gonna butcher this but
translated to shoot the boar or kill the
boar is a controversial South African
song and the idea behind it is that it's
they're talking about white like white
people or white um rich white people I
know they had a I know they had a
diameter they they had like a weird
genocidal problem or whatever where a
lot of white farmers were getting
um yeah that's a different story Yeah
by different gangs and stuff to just
take their land the guy was just
murdered that way yeah just happened
this week yeah it's crazy man but it's
funny that the same side that could call
This Racist can also unracist that song
which is like or that chant they do and
it's like come on man I think the [__]
up part about all of this is like
there's it's just the back and forth
like Vengeance thing is like
justification through oh this happened
to my people and then they're going oh
well you're doing this to our people and
in whatever group you are like they're
all justifying the violence or whatever
saying like well we can and say this and
do this because it happened to so and so
or whatever and I'm like all across the
board there should just be a
straight up standard of like you
probably don't want to [__] justify
any violence I just wish that they would
just tell me what happened and then I
could make up my own mind but they don't
they don't do that like this killed you
mean like the news like is is just
creating they tell you what to think
like this kill the board thing they say
this is why it's not this and but you
should just tell me where it is yeah so
it's a it they're like it's an
anti-apartheid South African struggle
song Cool tell me that yeah tell me that
that's it but you don't have to say this
is why it's not racist it's like well
we're broke and that's like the headline
yeah that's the first thing yeah so no
no so no news is new I mean everything's
an opinion piece right there's no news
anymore think about the snark of every
single everything that we hear that's
controversial they say no comma this
isn't what happened and it's like you
can just tell me what happened yeah
that's just but that you're violating
click bait rules though that's what
makes BuzzFeed BuzzFeed but that's what
I figured it too but yeah mainstream
media is left by default like why why
can't people think it's institutions
based like colleges and [__] like that
like it's super institutionalized why do
you have to dig so deep to find the
opposite side like that's kind of weird
just be non-partisan yeah
would that be easier too as like a news
media but it doesn't get the job done
that's the problem well if you're too
balanced and like not extreme enough you
you're probably just uninteresting yeah
that's that's what it's looked at as now
right yeah Chris Center you're right
it's a it's a good song it's a good song
and it's giving good examples of good
[__] they're not telling you to do
anything bad it's just hey like look at
this life isn't this objectively nice
yeah I actually want to live in a small
town and live in a simpler life I like
that I like knowing who the the grocery
store person is like dope that's my
[__] dream yeah it's [__] stupid
and everybody tries to simulate that
within their own pocket it is it's a
goal that everyone already has yeah I
want to know my neighbors and watch out
for each other and then like I would
like a place where hey if there's a
robbery going down we all go and help
yeah everyone stops it instead of being
like Oh I don't want to get sued oh like
in this big city there's dude I think
there's you you treat humans less human
it just happens hell yeah it happens
since I've been walking my dogs more I
got to know all the neighbors and all
the other dog walkers and my block and
it's like it's a cool feeling to be like
hey what's up good to see you how's
everything like you know yeah just
chatting some [__] on like a on a Monday
morning like it's not because I don't
think this is like a race thing I think
there's a clear difference between
country living and City living yeah and
all over the world city people are
[__] [__] and country people are
just kind Souls yeah but also City
people don't give each other the chance
to find out if you're an [__] or not
City people just mind their own business
and they it's like there's a wall all
the time yeah yeah but I think I think
it makes sense because you have to be
because in the city has tons of people
you get burned way more yeah there's
angrier people there's just a lot of
existence it's just harder to know
everybody
people will assume that you don't like
them already or they'll assume that they
don't like you it's like [__] weird I
don't like country music straight up I
don't like it
foreign
[Music]